hi guys how's it going so today we're
here at lunch
these are my absolute you are killing
and you were six months I'm happy on
food you can't wait to hear a new music
from landing hi guys we'll see you in
the next clip my entire body is hurting
from yesterday's workout like I can't
even get off this bag you don't know
what I got in your dress Oh 25 is
anything over Maddie these are for you
baby girl your outfit have I hit a new
low maybe are these for children just
like my hangers for babies I mean this
is amazing I don't even hang up my own
clothes yeah I don't you don't have to
take it I already know I'm self aware
do you want to go do I get out my key
well you have to have it you start the
car I think wow I started the car I
drove
we're industry no one's excited
fussing about we're at front we've
filmed here so many times
spitting brunch and doing the same thing
over and over and over again that's why
I think daily vlogging is kind of silly
because honestly a lot of us have the
same schedules and we do the same thing
and it's not that entertaining did you
film front yesterday until the brunch
but I filmed the girls at the front we
had a really fun time I wish you would
have came I had cramps yeah you would
not be able to get a little workout it
was pretty intense
I was just like I almost dropped like I
was going to say that I drop my camera a
little bit ago as I almost dropped my
coffee but I've been sitting here and
it's so crazy because I guess they don't
want to call third street and there's a
lot of tourists so a lot of people
aren't from around here and for some
reason I see so many of you guys here
it's like I have a meet up every time on
Third Street
you're very easy a spot
yeah I don't know what I'm saying anyway
uh we're doing shut up
it's like he's free but he's not look at
your long leash good boy Pike is going
well Maddie's being pretty well-behaved
my biggest concern is with him not
having a leash is just running and going
home with somebody else cuz he doesn't
really have much loyalty but I think
he's getting better look look look how
good dog training it's difficult you
know I think is even more difficult in
dog training probably training a child
great view good choice Maddie we let
Maddie pick where you wanted to go and
he decided to take a turn so here we are
going up this hill but we've never gone
up we'll trap a lot of shape okay but
I'm not ready
oh boy great you exhausted I need to
shake a little break here just like a
little rest
good eye
you're more fit than us that's cuz
you're young and vibrant Rho and
humanity you sound so sad I'm so tired
right there but I tried to fit giving
watery good one
look at our dirty boy why is he hiding
back there oh you're so gross Wilkins
I'm going to switch out one of my new
Apple watches with no Jennifer Hollett
looks nice I need a nap before we go
anywhere tonight okay what don't you
want it you're holding it no oh this
looks nice
I just hate that they made this white
case with such a prominent Apple logo on
the back no oh you're vlogging Jay
Genesis actually this is a continuation
of probably the past three days of my
blog pretty look good I just wanted to
say something before I leave this is
garbage
there needs to be
I lose my coupons that I get money Bed
Bath & Beyond you don't need this wait
like every day in the mail like you
thought they text me every five days
there's got to be an upgrade that that's
that's a waste of paper an absolute
waste of paper all right we gotta go
take Maddie to get his anal glands
expressed oh my god what a Monday
is it Monday today it is money today oh
god I have so much to do this is what
this looks like this looks like a
tornado what they're here yeah can they
have okay nice pack up your body so
tired from his hike yesterday like I'm
not gonna be able to get him out of here
is there a baby boy back there but you
guys can see him he looks so ratchet cuz
every time we take him for a hike he
gets so gross and dirty and even though
we'd give him a bath it's just it
doesn't matter you just can't get that
dirt off he needs a professional it was
rubbish
my sister and I are also planning to go
to Germany this year and I'm really
excited going down all this is the time
frame when we can go is during VidCon so
unfortunately I'm not going to VidCon
this year and it's kind of insane
because I've been to every VidCon so far
I do plan on going on tour one day
whether it's for Maddie's tour to meet
all of you guys but what I do want to do
is since we'll be going to Germany we
don't know where we're going yet so
leave us some comments where you think
we should go we could potentially go up
anywhere anywhere that we can get to by
train or plane or automobile
and I do want to do a meet-up somewhere
over there so that's gonna be a to be
determined I'll be so much fun I love
going and traveling and getting to meet
you guys because it really honestly
makes making YouTube videos worthwhile
because you sit and you get so kind of
captivated by making sure you're grading
content and making sure you're posting
videos the point that you don't really
enjoy doing it anymore and I think that
is a struggle that I am kind of going
through for the past couple of years and
now I've kind of enjoyed making videos
again and it's sort of been a fun
experience I might make a video talking
about that another day but I don't want
it to be one of those oh my god watch my
blog this 500 hour video talking about
how sad I am because that's not the case
it's just a very weird situation and a
lot of things happen in life a lot of
things you guys don't see on camera and
how do you decide what to share and what
not to share and I think a lot of people
are online they share too much you don't
have to share everything and being a
vlogger what is that fine line of I'm
not going to film this moment or I am
going to film this moment I think I
finally figured out the perfect balance
so it's it's kind of helped me save my
sanity also getting Maddie has been
incredible I know you guys see him all
the time in my videos but his sort of
given me another reason to do things
he's also kind of spurred my creativity
to start doing music and to want to tour
it he like our little buddy he's a lot
of work
don't get me wrong but man he's been so
much fun to sort of just hop around and
the fact that we just saved him from the
rescue and all he was so little like
poor baby
so Monday morning that run I'm exhausted
I did not sleep well last night because
it ranged so there was like a small have
to turn your push I can turn this way I
gotta do a u-turn don't tell don't tell
anybody
keep your mouth shut this stays between
us how are you don't don't tell anybody
about EJ I don't see any no u-turn signs
so I'm gonna take what's mine let me out
of your Pig
look how you need a you need a scrub
done at the vet he was a very good boy
they said to be careful and to
potentially puts the comb back on him
again to make sure that he's not looking
for him some little final remaining
stitches so hopefully we don't have to
do that either be good boy now that
you're okay see on the way to take
Maddie to the groomers I feel like my
entire life revolves around this dog now
but that's fine
I'm also using a different GoPro so I'm
wondering if there's any difference
it looks like this is the GoPro session
so it's the little square one before I
was using the GoPro black with the
battery's dead
and that previous clip was the GoPro
Hero let's go get you back oh I love
live
are you ready to go I'm waiting for
Manny to get his hair done and I'm
trying to install the watch OS update
but for some reason I had no idea that
it was even out I don't know how I
missed it because I thought that I had
already done the update but it never
actually ever completed it all the time
I thought I had the newest OS and guess
what I did not I might as well just go
home and finish this update I think this
guy's fresh blowouts and I think this is
gonna be the end of this vlog so see you
guys later I'm gonna listen to some REM
that was just a tree almost all of the
new ones that they announced fairly
recently at the Apple town hall event